yo bullet cat podcast
hey man shout out to the homie tootsie
in the building
hey man last time i saw you was like in
february before the whole goddamn
pandemic
kicked off um you was obviously in a
different space
because now you you know you're the
young superstar now yeah i'm
[Music]
yeah uh it's crazy because i i just
revisited that interview and uh
you you said the same thing you just
said on my hygiene store the girl the
girlfriend asked caresser
so i'm assuming that the uh amount of
other dudes
females whom you're uh participating in
is has gone up since the last time i saw
you yeah
you know wife i asked chris or no the
white so you're [ __ ] these wives now
yeah wife you know baby mama was all
that
somebody get it let me ask you a
question yeah
cause when i was a savage i just had a
rule if somebody was married
i wouldn't [ __ ] with them now if they
had a man i'd almost be like
even better yeah because then they they
ain't tripping it's like this
if you marry and i'm [ __ ] your wife
that [ __ ] still don't got nothing to do
with me so i don't care you know what
i'm saying i'm
i'm only 20 i ain't getting married
right now and [ __ ]
i know if i had a wife [ __ ] would be
[ __ ] my wife
what i know if i had a wife [ __ ] to
[ __ ] my wife you think that [ __ ] gonna
look at me and be like
yeah nah she married i ain't gonna [ __ ]
her so you're saying that you would
marry the type of woman who would [ __ ]
other men
no i would marry a woman that's going to
be so bad that other [ __ ] are wanna
[ __ ] her
wanna [ __ ] them you said that they're
gonna be fine nah other [ __ ] will [ __ ]
my wife like
i know they they would they'd be in yeah
they would but you're actually going
through it
yeah for sure i'm the one going through
with the [ __ ] though if she [ __ ]
somebody else you know
so let me ask you a question are you
done are you afraid any sort of karma
blowing back for when you do decide to
get married i feel like i am karma
you are karma it's a big statement bro i
don't even know what that means but i
feel like i am come
okay so i feel like i did my dirt i had
repercussions already have you ever
had a somebody's husband uh like trying
to
hit you like what the [ __ ] bro nah cause
[ __ ] the the usually the wives that i'll
be [ __ ] like they
they husbands be like locked up and [ __ ]
oh see you
i can't be telling all my business so
you you're [ __ ]
okay so you'll [ __ ] uh a wife whose
husband is locked up what
okay let me ask you a question do you
draw the line in the sand
if it's a wife whose like husband is in
the army overseas
or it's fair game um
i feel like bro i honestly just feel
like if i had a wife
[ __ ] will [ __ ] my wife so if [ __ ]
are [ __ ] my wife
like why should i not [ __ ] other [ __ ]
wives like
like real [ __ ] you only live once yo man
i
you got a crazy philosophy but you know
hey you're 20 years old bro
so ain't nobody can really tell you a
goddamn thing chilling though
now i'll be chilling now though man
i'll be chilling have you ever had had
been at a bitch's house and then like
her significant other pull up
nah i haven't been at a girl house
though and her dad
her dad pulled up because you know i'm
still young right right
right feel me but this happened like two
years ago
she'll be piping like a little 17 18
year old when you're like 17
18. nah when i was when i turned 18 that
was the cutoff line no i mean like
maybe when you were when you were seven
years old and i was 17 yeah yeah yeah
but i was 18 though at the time so you
know at 18 people
people stood up with their parents of
course back so shorty was 18 i'm 18. i'm
thinking her [ __ ] i'm talking
about [ __ ]
[ __ ] so i so i'm i got around the bed
like we in a pitch dark me and her
laying in the bed
[ __ ] my producer
and [ __ ] another girl laying on
the on the ground
like her and like yo they so boom me and
shorty on the bed my producer and
another shorty on the ground like they
laying on a bed
clearly a one-bedroom house yeah facts
i'm like so boom right i'm on a bed
piping her like it's
mad quiet in here but the shorty that's
on the ground got a son
her son is in there in the room while
you're piping
my producer ruthless he piping
shorty while her son is like how old is
her son
like three oh so he's like he could walk
what he knew what was going on he had to
know what was going on
oh piping her i'm talking about boom
next thing i know [ __ ] he leaves out the
house like
it's time for his little boy no no your
producer my producer he about the house
it's time for us to go
he leave out the house her dad wake up
her dad
wakes up and comes in a room i'm hiding
under the bed
like i'm talking about he cut the light
on and everything like
what's going on in here like yo i'm like
yo bro hey
and i swear i lied to not i had to be
like in
in like gang man like i had to be like
in
like the hispanic territory like i was
in the wrong territory i like to not
like the corner stores was still open it
was like two in the morning
so he was piping a latina i ain't gonna
say that
you know those latin fathers are afraid
i did just say that though right you did
yeah they're gonna get me
well no them latino i mean my wife's
mexican uh my baby mom is mexican hey
protect me well you know the interview
no the the the
you know hey man that's one thing i'm
scared of is a mexican father bro
now real talk that's what i'm saying
like i'm talking about yo like where we
was at like it was machetes on the
ground
oh [ __ ] yeah like spring where's the
three-year-old by the way
at this point man under the bed with you
no oh
no like hiding out like hey we're
playing hide and seek bro
are you my dad at this point at this
point yo and you know
kids like talk so i'm so glad he didn't
say nothing because like
what if he was like grandpa he under the
bed
oh man i'd be there right now you might
be no energy
you did you know that her dad was asleep
when you was piping
yeah so you was in there like yo look
we're going to sneak in the shorties
crib
me and the homie thanks
be quiet we go keep the kid in here i
don't i yo listen i'm gonna keep him
steady
he more messed up to me because i know
that kid's [ __ ] now because he
witnessed his mom getting
getting rolled on and then her homie
getting rolled on x
no no no her cut yeah whatever it was
but
i'm talking about he's gonna grow a buck
wild bro i'm piping her
piping her did he like did you like
chuck the dude's like what's a little
man just
no it was pitch black did you pass on my
ipad
it was pitch bla he was on the phone no
he was on the phone
yeah that's what you got to do yes but
exactly you got the right idea yo here's
my here's my phone what games you like
it was angry birds youtube it was dumb
late at night
ryan's toy review go over there and i'm
gonna [ __ ]
yeah yeah facts she was getting piped
though well i'm glad that you're still
here man i'm glad that
that that that i'm heading to the store
because like i'm telling you when i when
i
when i walked to that corner store and i
seen the corner store was still open and
the autumn people was outside the corner
store i'm like i'm definitely dumb
are you um so since the pandemic has
started it's actually been it's crazy
because
you and your label and your crew have
had
such a there's been a lot of artists who
you've noticed
um this has affected them in a negative
way whether it's they didn't have the
work ethic to push through what's going
on in the world or whatever
but i feel like y'all yeah
moving the baby had one of the craziest
years of his life in the middle of the
world being shut down
and your [ __ ] has gone up like a hundred
times i made a post right
and i'm like you know um one of the i i
called him one of the biggest artists in
the world
and people dead tried to fake like this
[ __ ] like not one of the biggest like
they like they like
i don't know if i wanted to he's did you
did y'all see what this [ __ ] literally
did
in the middle of a [ __ ] pen no no
it's it's a that's a fact
there's no i just don't feel like
there's any disputing you can't you
can't argue with that
did you see what he did in the middle i
sure hate her yeah you that people be
haters
you know the one thing like like i i was
like oh the baby fan not quite
you know when he was at south by with
the diapers and [ __ ] but like
i used to sell weed and [ __ ] so the
baby's [ __ ] like early on was like
it was like pusha t talking about coke
the baby talking about moving packs
very relatable thanks that's the only
thing i was missing off the last time
i missed all that pack talk bro you know
what i'm saying but yo it's just it's
just a testament to you and your your
team bro like
you know even black sacks doing this
thing but like your [ __ ] has
taken the [ __ ] off um congratulations
like it was crazy
i remember when we got the call that we
were like adding your record with summer
walker rotation here in l.a i was like
wait we can we're playing them
yeah the homie [ __ ] yeah i appreciate
that for real bro like that [ __ ]
all the blessing i didn't expect for
that [ __ ] to take off like as fast as it
did
like yeah no the love cycle records
going up the album
man that album was that uh when your
album dropped and it did as well as it
did on on billboard
was that um prior to the capital
situation
or was that you or was that with capital
i'm not it was with capital
okay it was it was wicked it just you
guys hadn't had you guys hadn't
announced we hadn't announced
okay i mean like i've been signing
capital for a minute and everybody as
soon as i announced it they're like
oh he sold the soul he's not going to
drop as much music as he used to be
dropping it's like
i've been signing with them like this
whole time i've been dropping like
they've been with them yeah i just
didn't know they didn't know yeah in
fact so it ain't no different
nah i think it's dope man um you and
summer walker on a record together
that's that's a big feature man like
like she must have been really she must
have really [ __ ] with your [ __ ] like
how did that happen
um honestly it had happened because i
was on tour with her you know when it
came time
oh by the way does london on the beat
know that you're that you're notorious
for
uh but well well see that's the thing
because it's a respect okay okay for
sure
as long as you respect her boyfriend you
ain't yeah that's a respect man we cook
up
all right for sure yeah no he's great
for sure it's respecting god never
i mean anyway i'm sorry to detract what
you were saying because continue don't
look at me like that either so it's not
anything but yeah though you know we um
i was on tour with her
um we had we like she had she
she liked my music she was [ __ ] with
me um had game time for
a remix i'm like yo [ __ ] if someone
don't get out there i don't want nobody
else on it like
they had to make it happen cause if they
make it happen i was gonna find a way to
make it happen
that's facts like real talk i won't lie
i might be one of the only artists like
besides like maybe like young boy that's
like signed to a label
that like still do what they want like
real talk like i do what i want
like and my my label
you know they they with it that's why i
[ __ ] with capital so much because
[ __ ] like i ain't pointing them in the
wrong direction yet like i haven't did
nothing wrong yet so like i mean
that'd be cool yeah talk about i feel
like i got one of the best presidents in
the game
which are we talking about arnold or
we're talking about the capitals
yeah arnold's man arnold's killing it
yeah what was it about
uh about arnold and and and his label
his situation that like drew you to like
trust you know rocking with them because
you probably could have you know
probably signed with anybody honestly i
i feel like what
what what pointed me to arnold so much
was the fact that he had baby and what
he was doing with baby
and the thing that the the direction
that he was trying to go for
you know the carolinas as whole uh with
the carolinas he
he was just trying to paint you know the
same image that you know um
not as what qc in them had for atlanta
but like all right
um home is home is where the heart is
you look what i'm saying and
and we don't really have much that come
out of here i see people leave out of
the city
leave out of the carolinas and um and
venture out and go here and do this with
these people why y'all
doing the same thing home like i seen
him do an interview right
and he like um how come y'all go out of
town
hey i go party and i go do all of this
out of town but
i don't do the same [ __ ] at home like
y'all not going to these clubs turning
up at these clubs
doing the [ __ ] [ __ ] with the people
that's in your city and like i feel like
he was he notorious for that like
he he notorious for making a way out of
the people that was right there
surrounded in the carolinas like south
coast is a
is a carolina-based label no for sure
so we got south carolina and north
carolina i think you guys are creating
like a
culture for that yeah region you know
because
we i mean there's been anecdotal
anecdotal
artists that like petey pablo and like
when i was a kid you know what i'm
saying but like
you know my manager uh used to manage
petey pablo hey p
pablo was hard i didn't even know who he
was because you know i'm not from
i'm not from you were from syracuse
until you're about 13 right yeah
facts i'm from syracuse so when i moved
to north carolina
and like they talking about petey pablo
petey pablo was lit though
i mean you're you're way younger than me
he didn't even know he was
one of them ones he was on the cover of
double xl he made the song
um raise up north carolina not that song
from north carolina i ain't freaking
leak freak a leak
bruh i know that yeah i'm like
yo this [ __ ] he that [ __ ] he's on
goodies with sierra
yes right yeah like free hey petey
pablo's that dude
i'm like yo that like he that [ __ ] like
for real like
you made freakily that was my [ __ ] i
ain't even i
i yo i had no idea it's from carolina oh
the girl who
who the girl who the girl that was like
we made it recently like she was in it
she was in a video oh i don't know man
listen
some girl right she was so [ __ ] bad i
used to look at her in the video like
and be like drooling now them old school
video vixens were something special
yo it was like gloria velazquez it's
just me so sexy
yeah like uh what was that bitch's name
uh
god i shouldn't say what was that
bitch's name out loud i might get
cancelled what was that young
respectable female's name
vida guerra she was like remember king
magazine
rosa rosa was a little later she vita
yeah she said
i mean she might have an only fans to be
clear i don't know rosa costa has a
is it a costa she has an alley fans
gloria velez is definitely probably a
grandma at this point
no no no no i don't i don't subscribe
i'm a married
hey how many only fans accounts have you
subscribed to so far a lot
you so you're a supporter of yes it's
kind of
do you do you look at it like it's
better than porn because you feel like
you kind of like
the girls like accessible right it's
almost like you know them
facts yeah i feel like i could [ __ ] you
so why not get a preview like some money
in your pocket
like and it helped like yo like i
so like boom let me see like what she
like
working with for [ __ ] so have you ever
subscribed to a woman's only fans
account and then [ __ ] her after
yes nice multiple times yes
what do you dammer only know what though
or on ig and say yo i support what
you're doing
but you know what though [ __ ]
i just linked with a girl
not too long ago [ __ ]
her only fans ain't looking like her in
person
in a bad way it's like you saw her in
person you're like yo what's up
got a catfish on the only thing you got
catfished did you still [ __ ] though of
course you did no
no you didn't oh self-power self-control
rather yeah
you got to respect it gotta respect it
so only fans
i feel like is like the quarantined
strip club right better
it's better better so
yo yo the [ __ ] ain't done [ __ ]
they know them [ __ ] ain't
ain't doing what they doing only fans in
the strip club
that's true they're getting crazy i only
think what's
so i haven't subscribed to any only fans
accounts because i have
uh i'm just not i'm very frugal with my
money
man listen i feel like there's enough
free porn pornographic material in the
world
it's worth it i'm also a married man so
my wife would slice my throat if she
if she so your wife your wife you'll get
in trouble for watching porn no no no i
get in trouble if i spent money
to watch a [ __ ] my wife
is very clear i probably watch yeah i
watch porn but if if she were to go on
our bank statement
and see me running up a only fantasy
that's why you gotta go get y'all oh
[ __ ] you gotta go get you a little
pipe and [ __ ] i mean i'm just not i'm
not to be clear like yo if they look at
my business account [ __ ]
yo why should you say only fans only
fans i'll be investing
so it's like a write-off for you thanks
you could just say that you're doing
research for girls for your videos
thanks oh tax write-off on the only fans
right off our only fans
yeah yeah you want to shout out your
favorite only fans accounts
give shine the lighthouse girl it's this
girl name like story they love story
nasty like what should be doing on there
yo
everything is this girl named gabrielle
monique doing some nasty [ __ ] hey nasty
like when you say nasty what do you mean
so i don't know what nasty means to you
hey
my my 33 year old definition of nasty
might be just off the charts it's
another girl
it's a girl her name like what it's
like a little but they nasty though i
mean look
like mr miss strokes something it's
mister and mystery
nasty taco more like what's the nastiest
[ __ ] you've seen on only fans i don't
know i like that [ __ ] though that's
we're talking all right so boom hold on
let me just clear some up cause they're
gonna think like i got a porn addiction
hey if you do it's okay i don't got no
porn addiction because cause only fans
isn't porn hey who just got banned like
from the nfl or something for like
a porn addiction or something listen if
they're banning people for porn
addictions then [ __ ]
who was it someone kicked me off the
internet somebody got banned for they
but i'm telling you like yo yo real [ __ ]
sometimes i don't give [ __ ] with nobody
say sometimes porn be better than [ __ ]
well i don't dis i don't i don't
disagree with you in terms of
uh you know it's it's sometimes you know
what
that should take too much energy it's
certainly it's certainly um
like you said time consuming it's time
consuming you gotta have a girl come
over then you gotta even if you're not
if you just wanna [ __ ] you gotta make
her feel good about [ __ ] yeah
and it it's definitely too much or you
could just log on to browsers
and just you know just i don't got that
though i get you
some hacked passwords oh you know what i
used to use the hat [ __ ]
i hate use them since in a minute listen
sir
for the sake of me being videotaped
right now and whether or not my wife
watches this
i got you [ __ ] yo i used to have all the
brides and
[ __ ] i don't got none of them since hey
back in the day
bang bros browsers all that [ __ ] going
up i used to yo i used to watch i ain't
gonna who's your favorite porn star
[ __ ]
i don't lie i ain't been watched ever
since only fans i ain't really
look at the old school ones like back in
the day uh i like sarah banks
okay you know sarah banks i know who she
is yeah i like sarah banks i always
know how old you are based on who your
favorite porn star is i like
i like talking to girls hey man hey
back in the day prior to your porn
watching
uh timeline in life there was a girl
named cherokee
there was pinkie i know cherokee i know
pinkie pinkie was like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
she was almost like a [ __ ] but i never
seen how big pinkie was but
she was a real short light skinned fat
ass
everybody knows lacy duvall
lacey duvall was a legend i don't know
lacy the world there was a black chick
named heather hunter who was like the
original
og she dark skin no she was like a light
but she was like the almost like the
the jenna james you know who jenna
jameson is nah so jenna jameson is like
the michael you know everybody gonna
come on and say
[ __ ] so they like uh tiana trump oh yeah
tiana trump is
um obviously the hot you know she i
don't really care for her
she been popping though she alright she
went to jail and then came out like you
know [ __ ] boozy
when busy came out of jail everybody was
she came out her [ __ ] went up
but yeah a lot i ain't even gonna say
that because she's gonna get talking
[ __ ] about me like
i gotta watch what i say now cause i'm a
little bit bigger hey [ __ ] it man let
her fly
but i was just gonna say like [ __ ] like
well i don't know if like you know a lot
of rap [ __ ] like have [ __ ] her but
like oh a lot for sure
yeah okay i know she [ __ ] bill maher
who's uh he hosts the show on hbo old
white man i guess he paid her to [ __ ]
what other rap [ __ ] [ __ ] she [ __ ]
trippy red so she talked about that
and then she told me um i'd be like i
like i interviewed her and she was
talking some wild
she's [ __ ] off the chain by the way
she because she
uh honey yeah and i'm pretty sure
i'll tell you off the air there was r b
singer
who she said that she used to [ __ ] who
who would like she would like put things
up dude's ass
oh yeah like some like and and then i
get
i guess who it was during the interview
and i
i may or may not have been right i don't
want people to go find the interview and
be like that guy
but yeah i'll tell you but yeah she's
she's definitely she's all the way the
[ __ ] out here she's [ __ ] nfl players
nba players
but she ain't she fronting about i like
that exclusive [ __ ] though
good luck man i will i'll be finding
them though
just not on only fans see i i'm young
hey let me ask you this hold on not our
only thing bad [ __ ] on only fans want
you to be like her male model in the
video but it's pov
so you're not in it yeah but you're
holding the camera yeah
would you do it huh
nah i can't you could you have do you
have tattoos that would like
like be the giveaway no i mean if you're
holding you know no i'm talking about
like
you got like stomach tattoos or anything
no oh you get away with it then but see
the thing is though she's gonna come out
and be like yeah you're right you're
right you can't trust these on yeah
no that ain't me uh uh man the
[ __ ]
i seen some [ __ ] that went viral a
[ __ ]
kevin gates [ __ ] they said it but
he's trying to say it won't him
oh yeah that's you know man
like you know what's crazy like if it
wasn't him
boom i like now that i told like now
y'all have started something like i
don't like that [ __ ]
yeah i uh yeah man
i don't want to look at that i don't
want to see that i accidentally i
accidentally saw tiger's dick on twitter
whoa
he [ __ ] it was trending i clicked on
it this full starter the only fans that
posted a picture of his dick it was
[ __ ] all over twitter i accidentally
saw it it's not like i went looking for
it
i was like [ __ ] vietnam now i got
tiger's dick in my [ __ ] head pause
no homo you know what i'm saying jesus
christ
yeah but yo it's crazy because tiger's
so poppin but this fool starts a only
fan's account
and posts his dick on there like ain't
you more popping than that
like shouldn't you some [ __ ] don't
give a [ __ ] clearly
some [ __ ] don't go i give a [ __ ] you
should i give
don't go that route sir yeah real [ __ ]
like if i i like
it lose value feel me 100
like they females like you a little bit
more
when you were a little bit picky with
the [ __ ] i be picky with the [ __ ] like
i'm telling you robbie listen now hey
i [ __ ] one ugly [ __ ] your whole life
one was how was it great
i feel like uh the rule of thumb usually
is if a girl is ugly or fat
yeah that they have to never [ __ ] the
fat girl though they have to compensate
being ugly or fat with their skills yeah
so but but but i never [ __ ] the fat
girl
um it depends on also what we're
defining as fat to be clear
by the way not trying to fat shame here
shout out you're not lucky
[ __ ] don't fat shame but like real [ __ ]
like
i'm gonna hunt it like i ain't i'm first
of all
like real [ __ ] i'm a capricorn so i'm
blunt like oh i'm gonna keep it a buck
with you i don't know what that means i
mean i know that that's it
i'm not tapped
[Music]
february or january january 27th yeah
yeah so you blunt
yeah oh for sure for show so yeah yeah
so that's what i'm saying
i'm a capricorn so i'm blunt like i tell
it
i don't give a [ __ ] about none of that
like if you fat you fat that's fair like
i don't fat shame but if you fat you fat
like
i got cousins them [ __ ] is fat they
fat they can't help it they fat
you if you no they can help it yeah they
can help with it but be clear
now if you're ugly you might not be able
to help that without saying yeah nah
that's a fact but like [ __ ]
like everybody got somebody for them
if you're big and you don't like being
big lose weight if you
yeah i mean if you feel as if you ugly
i got homies whose type yeah are
literally just
really big white women word yes
are we talking about caucasian men or
i'm talking about some of my friends
who are african-american and they like
i've known
certain friends of mine since high
school pogs
and the only time i've ever seen them
with women
is big fat white [ __ ] pogs
what does that mean fat ass white girls
oh wow pogs park
i like that you learn new things so i
have friends that's not that's a
whatchamacallit i'm porn
oh that's a that's a [ __ ] category oh
[ __ ]
that's a pornhub category thanks bbw
pugs
bugs damn but i think that they're
i'm talking like fat though man paul i'm
talking like
my i have a friend i might put his name
out there he knows who he is if he
watches this
like one baby mama is just a giant
ex-wife is a giant current woman is a
giant
he got a giant giant woman like like
we're talking like
like if rod wave was like a white woman
that kind of size i [ __ ] with right away
me too but he's a bigger dude so that's
what i'm gonna say right
no i mean like like like this the white
people don't get on me
they're gonna get on me no i love
broadway [ __ ] shout out to saint pete
i i
[ __ ] with wrong way but he's a bigger
dude so imagine
a woman rod wave size but just with
white skin
and uh an unpleasant face you know that
hey
you know so crazy that'd be another
thing too
but they also will let you write off
their kids on your ta on your taxes like
my big girls is thorough yeah big girls
is thorough
i don't even yo we're going to get down
a big a big tunnel of
of anyway um yeah now we gonna get
canceled he this [ __ ] just mentioned
ride wave
like no no no they might not they might
be they're in the comments
in the comments every [ __ ] everybody
get us they definitely about to get us
talking i ain't saying nothing i [ __ ]
around
listen i [ __ ] with all the rappers yeah
i mean so we don't [ __ ] with all the
rappers
he [ __ ]
and i respect it because it's like you
can't say certain [ __ ] about
people because certain people don't take
[ __ ] as
jokes they shouldn't take it the way it
was intended they just take it and they
were like
yeah but [ __ ] like you're right broadway
might be the kind of guy who's not not
rich i'm gonna tell you something
it's like boom you can't like you you
can't do nothing but respect it because
[ __ ] you can't play with somebody that
you don't like really know like that
like
so boom but now i have seen pnb rock say
something about
right i've saw the the back of the court
they had but [ __ ] it started it
escalated quickly yeah
and broadway was on some don't come to
florida yeah
it has started it has started from
[ __ ]
pnb has said like he was joking you
talking about what he said about singing
yeah you could have took an offense to
that yeah yeah yeah
facts facts so boomi had started from
that and it was like damn when i seen a
show i'm like i
i kind of understand because it's like
[ __ ] bro don't you know
bro don't know you you know what i'm
saying so and although you might [ __ ]
with his [ __ ] you know
like so [ __ ] like i but i hope they i
hope they
i mean get that together because at the
end of the day [ __ ] ain't a rap [ __ ]
that i don't
i'm not beefing with no rap [ __ ] like
real [ __ ] like i got [ __ ] that i
really don't like
like right right so we're talking about
like in real life yeah real life like
[ __ ] who like actually like
don't play with me so for you to like i
mean but i [ __ ] with everybody though
you and you and baby still haven't done
a record right nah
never is that is it babies it's so crazy
because me and baby
ain't never like really used to talk i
remember you saying that
and how dope was it that he just gave
you that co-signed a few weeks ago a lot
of [ __ ]
it's real like it's kind of like [ __ ]
like because i never really saw him
talking about you either
but he just co-signed the [ __ ] out of
you i worked my like baby will tell you
though like [ __ ] i was on toys with him
you feel what i'm saying and like i work
my
ass off to get to like where i'm at
today so
[ __ ] it's like um it was a respect thing
like
like them i could respect what they had
[ __ ] doing and [ __ ] i just appreciate
that [ __ ] for real for
like oh for sure because like not it's
not like i waited for that
but like i for you to be like you know
you're somebody from the state
that gives you some validation most
definitely i never and we always talked
about like from
um from the label like the south coast
side like we always talked about how
like
[ __ ] i never had no cold sides like a
lot of and you don't want to force
like all right look we're on the same
labels you want that [ __ ] to come
naturally
shout me out like i never i've never
been that type [ __ ] like
i ain't never want to be no i don't like
features because i never wanted a record
to blow up
because of who's on it because who's on
it and then
i had i got a thousand and one songs
over here mm-hmm
um no i think that's dope i think now
though it's like only natural that's
gonna happen oh yeah
sure [ __ ] gotta have it just gotta have
i'm gonna drop again tonight
you dropping a record tonight yeah
called painting problems he shot it
oh she's dropping the video yeah he got
attacked his tag
oh drew t get the booty drew t
get the booty is that you yeah
drew see you get the booty yeah starting
to get the booty i mean it's got the
[ __ ] vintage social shirt on i see
yes
that was when sammy sosa was black facts
now he looks like me you see sammy's
also bleached his skin
no oh let me show you it's kind of
[ __ ] crazy to be honest
like like sammy so no so you you know
who sammy sosa is the baseball player
so when i was a kid in like 98 99 him
and mark maguire were those [ __ ]
dudes right
so this is how he used to look this is
how he looks now
um so he like
legit bleached his skin what oh my god
yeah that's kind of crazy right wait why
he do that though
uh i don't know i would i would argue to
say some some self-hate i'm not sure
i don't know but it's crazy because he
did he obviously didn't he did it on
purpose it's not like he doesn't have a
skin condition
like is it like michael jackson no no he
don't have vertiligo or whatever the
[ __ ]
i think he just has like like look at
this [ __ ] guy bro that shit's creepy
like i thought he like probably like
maybe did it too like no no he got some
he did like like i don't want to speak
on
on on on it too much because i'm not
fully educated but i know that in in
from what i
remember hearing in cuba that that's
like a thing that happens
like fools will go through bleaching
processes which is crazy
i don't know man shout out to sammy sosa
we're just shouting him out because he's
on this man's t-shirt over here
anyway uh yo so poetic pain obviously
your most successful project so far
yes sir but you've been dropping so much
i feel like there's
a plethora of music out there that
people might not even listen to this
might be their first time hearing you
yeah i'll be trying to stay consistent
bro
yeah like you're dropping tonight like
um
so the deluxe uh wave everyone's doing
deluxe
albums are i'm assuming your deluxe is
on the way
no you're just gonna drop something new
another tape
[ __ ] it when it's like why would i drop
six more songs on my project
when i could drop add five to it and
drop a whole another technique i mean i
i hear it i hear you i record too much
i'll be at the studio every day i saw
you say
that you prefer to record at home yeah
and you haven't found a studio that
makes you feel like you're at home yet
nah i found i found the engineer though
that's important i got i got two two of
them ty lee
and um it's another dude from atlanta
especially because since you're
you do the melodic singing [ __ ] having
the right engineer so important gotta
have the right engineer
do you have a [ __ ] [ __ ] y'all say bro
record here
whoever the [ __ ] his engineer is that
[ __ ] be going crazy
yes yeah nah i think um no finding the
right engineer is important for people
who do
who sing who do who do melodic [ __ ] but
when you record at home do you record
yourself yeah
so you're capable of like just rusting
your whole [ __ ] just doing it all
yourself
sex you make beats or anything nope i
don't know how to do that [ __ ]
yeah that's what i can learn yeah i feel
like you're doing like if i really like
i can learn that [ __ ] like that [ __ ] is
nothing
i feel like i feel like [ __ ] it's a lot
i could probably edit my own videos like
music videos if i wanted to
yeah if you can record yourself i always
tell people to talk [ __ ] yeah like
yeah i sit with him and i edit all the
way yeah if you i always tell people if
you have an audio if you're used to
audio software
yeah pro tools or audition whatever that
[ __ ] is just like it's just like that
but you it's just visually
you just yeah yeah final cut premiere is
obviously
there's a lot of nuance to that saying
that it's easy but if you can if you're
like
super in on audition or pro tools you
could figure out how to edit video
effects
that's right between watching youtube
and and
you know yeah you can figure it out oh
we're breaking down this video
we're not breaking it down we're taking
a break in the video to tell you all
about our sponsors
odd socks all right listen man uh
oddssocksofficial.com
what the [ __ ] was that bro uh it was
like a [ __ ] pomeranian hair floating
in the air
anyway odd socksofficial.com keyword
bootleg kev
go over there get you some socks and
you'll save 20 off if you use that
keyword they got south park
license they got some ghostbusters pimp
c
mike tyson really the one that i really
care about is they got that wwe license
you can get these awesome nwo socks
and then they got their odd socks basics
you know for all the basic [ __ ] get
you some basic socks
even though they are very comfortable uh
they're probably the most comfortable
socks
actually not probably definitively the
most comfortable socks i've ever put on
my feet
yes all right and that goes for all
types of socks
so go to oddssoxofficial.com get some
socks by the way
spongebob socks the kind of fly right
christmas time's on the way
use the keyword boolean kev 20 off
oddssocksofficial.com
support us by supporting oddsox let's go
so where hey where you originally from
i'm from phoenix bro
yo phoenix got some bad [ __ ]
that they do sir that they do i feel
like they got some of the baddest
females in the world you know what's
crazy is if this pandemic wasn't
going on i would already have booked you
out there at one of the clubs and i
would have already have taken you to the
illa strip club on the west coast i'm
telling you and had so much strange
vagina in your face
i never did a show out there you're
gonna go there and you're gonna be like
kev i love it here
oh yeah bro it's amazing i might gotta
go out there she's just shut down right
now
have you been still i mean i know it's
just parts of the country that aren't
shut down you just still doing some
shows i've got three shows this week
i got a show what's today thursday i got
a show tomorrow i gotta show saturday i
gotta show sunday where are all these
shows at i got a show on dayton ohio we
just came from columbus ohio last week
and it's not even no tour [ __ ] they just
keep booking me like
no that's crazy so when you do these
shows do you
like are you freaked out about catching
that rona you have no
have you caught the ronin yet i got it i
probably had i probably have i just
didn't know i
like i'm young yeah i had it in june was
it bad
i just couldn't smell i think it was a
time where i couldn't smell but like
you probably had the ronin yeah but so
so you're so
like it's crazy because if you're in la
you can't eat inside a restaurant you
got to be outside everything's closed
and then you'll go to like
like i'll see artists who are still
doing shows in parts of the country and
the [ __ ] is like
peck it's almost like the twilight zone
i'm like where
are they at it's like this [ __ ] isn't
even happening yeah
so ohio is turnt up ohio we turn
we got footage and everything what's
your favorite like or what is your
biggest market you think outside of home
new orleans yeah new orleans they love
you in new orleans
i love louisiana i wouldn't even say new
orleans louisiana
new orleans baton rouge that lafayette
new orleans is one of my favorite cities
i ever visited the world is is it
i love them i think they put voodoo on
me
hey shout out to voodoo are you a
religious guy
yeah like for real yeah like
like what's your uh what's your religion
if you had to classify it are you like
christian
christian okay yeah but
i ain't gonna get into that it's i wanna
i definitely wanna study like other
i mean yeah because i'm like i'm not
religious so
i'm not a big religion guy i'm very uh
i'm probably
i believe in god and i pray a lot
hey man like i pray so i probably i pray
you know how like
being muslim i think you gotta pray like
five times a day like
it seems like a lot of work to be muslim
shout out to the muslims yeah i
appreciate y'all's dedication you do
seem like it's a lot like
that we eat pork and like and all that
but like i love the swimming i can
honestly say that like i probably
i probably prayed like five times and
like
i ain't gonna get into it i feel like i
don't know
go ahead man let it let it go what were
you gonna say
you feel like what i don't really know i
don't i don't know
much about christianity but i know i'm
christian
because that's how i was raised so i
wanna i wanna dig
more into you know others i think it's
possible for you to believe in a god and
not have
and not be religious because religion
is a uh it's a very
man-made thing so you could be like you
could be spiritual you could believe in
god
but i feel like each religion
is created by man and there's a lot of
things that there's a lot of holes in a
lot of religions you you should
definitely look into it
i'm gonna look into it but i gotta
classify myself as
you know christian because that's why in
case you're in case you're your family's
watching
no no no your grandma yo what the [ __ ]
i raised you better than that yeah
that's how i was raised so i you know
i mean i classify myself as christian
hey that's dope
shout out to everybody out there you
know banging banging that god gang you
feel me
hey did you vote yeah was this your
first time going to your 20 so it had to
be your first time yeah first time
like i just had an argument with someone
yesterday about how important it is to
vote and
uh you know i think that's dope that you
voted
let's leave that sweater show everybody
that sweater black voters matter man
it's true
a little bit higher there he is
uh it's no no
no no but but it's crazy because that
sweater is the realest [ __ ] ever because
right now the reason why donald trump's
not about to be president
is literally because of black voters
[ __ ] him
[ __ ] him real [ __ ] [ __ ] him he could
suck my dick like real tuck
like he look like a piece of baloney
he doesn't yes he does for real like i
was looking at him he looked like
baloney with here
yeah he looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] is crazy i
just saw
he said they said they seen you see the
post where he said that he was jacking
off ghosts
oh where he's like this yeah safe to say
you're not doing the little pump feature
huh
yeah i ain't never even liked that [ __ ]
that's fair like real talk i don't
i don't even know why [ __ ] made him
famous like and i i don't really care
about rappers
real [ __ ] but like if he see this and he
like
try to get some clout i'm gonna let you
know bro like i already beat the [ __ ]
out you like
everything i love i believe that like
real [ __ ] i really beat the [ __ ] up with
him like
i don't need i believe that i don't even
play like this i think little pump
is um an a product of
the worst era in hip-hop history and
they're gonna and i'm gonna tell you
something they're gonna try to get i
know they're gonna try to get clout for
me
let me tell you something right rap
[ __ ] is gonna try me and i'm gonna let
y'all know right now like
i i'm not going back and forth on the
internet with y'all
i'm not gonna respond to y'all i'm gonna
get up with y'all
a little bit later that's what i'm gonna
tell y'all so like well i appreciate
what you've done
and that is not blow up because you're a
spectacle on the internet you've
blown up through hard work through the
catalog to
to building your fan base organically
and i think little pump is quite the
opposite
he blew up from being a spectacle yeah
like it was more about six nine is the
same people
if you ask me is the same people
what's worse being a snitch or
being a outspoken trumper in hip-hop
which one's worse man honestly i could
say
oh my god that's hard it's hard right
like i mean it's running around with the
mag like being a trumper
or being a snitch like that [ __ ] damn
their equivalent
like if you that shit's equivalent
i think it's it's close right it's
equivalent to snitching
so if you're yeah i think i think so
anybody out there if you and i don't
give a [ __ ] who like
what you did is what you did yeah you
feel what i'm saying
but if you did if you did go for him
honestly
you know what i say man that's what i
said [ __ ] over yeah i mean but [ __ ] you
for right now that's what i say
it's the difference between people who
voted for trump
and who ride around with the flags and
the hats sex
right there's [ __ ] they're i
call them cult members
but you know what though a lot of peop
you got
a lot of people who didn't vote for
biden
because of the tax increase
what i'm saying dumb [ __ ] this the
camera right here yeah
you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] the tax increase
was for people that was making 400 000
or more
or more but you ain't making that much
money getting broke
and you were talking about are you
worried about a [ __ ] tax increase
you was never you just ordered off the
dollar menu at taco bell
not even that like yo [ __ ] all right
he's gonna be president for like four
years probably not
another president come around and you
know we don't know how that's right
right right in four years [ __ ] you
wasn't gonna be rich
i'ma just be honest i you [ __ ] lazy
you've been broke you're gonna stay
broke and [ __ ] about you gonna change
you might as well both vote for biden
and not
and and and and and this is what i tell
people look
talking about a [ __ ] tax increase
[ __ ] you bro first of all the tax
increase thing is a very unrealistic
thing that's gonna get passed
yeah it's still gotta go through get
this orange [ __ ] the [ __ ] up out
of here and worry about everything
later yeah let's try to save the country
yo people used to
people used to yo i hear people talking
about yeah man people used to love
donald trump he used to be i ain't man
like i'm the [ __ ] if that [ __ ] like was
on wrestling and all that other [ __ ]
[ __ ]
well you know vince mcmahon is a
hardcore republican so yeah of course
he's honored
vince mcmahon's wife was a the small
business uh
consultant for the white house like like
she was a part of a
yeah linda mcmahon linda mcmahon vince
mcmahon's wife was
a part of trump's cabinet when he first
started she was a part of she ran the
small business [ __ ] for the country
yeah that the sba's was hitting though
no no i think she's got been gone since
then are you talking about the loans
that just happened
yeah no no this was early on oh i was
about to say it just was head [ __ ]
eating off them shits man but like no
[ __ ]
is crazy right now [ __ ] getting
locked up now you see the guy who rapped
about it and snitched on him yeah
facts i went to go uh get a lamb truck
i went to try to go get a lamb truck
boom i put my deposit down
[ __ ] they wasn't trying to sell me the
lamb truck because they thought she was
scamming
they thought i was scamming they said
skimmers was using like the ppps or
something like that peter i don't know
what the [ __ ]
first of all that's racist the fact that
they said if
let's be fair if i went in there they
probably wouldn't go to you
that's what i'm saying boom right i put
i even put my deposit down and
everything like
i would do blah all right so now like
my first truck first truck coming from
italy
all right boom it's it's on the boat
already yeah [ __ ]
they sell my [ __ ] i'm like from under
you
yes and then boom all right they build
me a new one all right boom they build
me a new one
next one get sold i'm like god damn like
then after a while the third one was
coming and like [ __ ] the [ __ ] they was
like yeah
it probably won't be here until next
time no it was a 2021 let's be honest
probably probably better yeah that's
probably not the smartest purchase for a
20 year old
uh you probably could have bought an
apartment complex i won't lie bro
or or literally anything else besides a
lamborghini truck
facts i've been buying cars for like you
know back to back now you got chill man
i know you invest that money i ain't
gonna go broke though i know you're not
i know you're not gonna go broke
but like wouldn't you rather you i feel
like you could all you could tell like
wouldn't you rather be worth like a
hundred million dollars in 10 years than
like 50.
my thing is though like jeff bezos
right right
what you can do with all that money like
i hear you you want to enjoy your money
thanks but his amount of money is an
unfathomable amount that's what i'm
saying though it's very
nice you know it's okay hammer blew all
his money and he made
probably more money than any rapper in
the night but you know it's okay it's
possible to
[ __ ] it all off yeah not not most
definitely but you know what's so crazy
he his you know how many generations of
like families are gonna be okay
because of him well if he wanted to like
end
like homelessness in america he could do
it right now and still be the richest
person in america i know that's just
crazy but he ain't doing that
because he's like [ __ ] dr evil
nonetheless
i love amazon big amazon shopper
i'm on that prime baby anyway you could
never go against amazon of course not
they just opened a [ __ ] uh a a a
grocery store in woodland hills that has
nobody in it
and smart grocery carts so when they
move yes without like they
literally put [ __ ] in the cart and it
already tells you what it is
and then you just walk out and it just
checks it out to your amazon account
it's [ __ ] crazy no bro that's that
jeff [ __ ]
but now what i'm saying is though feel
me like it's like yeah like no
i i can't foresee myself going broke i
want to invest in real estate
please get into real estate yeah real
estate is something that's not lambo
trucks no i'm going to get the lambo
truck in a few years
i want to invest in condominiums perfect
hey man
do it do it at home or do it in uh
i thought about texas a city like or
texas or or las vegas
there's no state tax you're you're
[ __ ] you know you're [ __ ] this guy's
smart
come on man uh there's no st tax in
florida but vegas
vegas is booming because what's about to
happen is everyone from l.a is about to
move to vegas yeah
so see but you know what's so crazy
though
invest in vegas and phoenix you got
people that live like
um here or like and they literally like
so like their business a lot of their
businesses are in vegas
listen but you got to be some of my
favorites some of my favorite rapper
friends who
who who live in la are from la they're
technically residents of las vegas but
you gotta end it so crazy because you
gotta be
over there for a certain amount of time
but they're they're over there but
they're not max
exactly they got a crib over there their
baby mama live over there
swiping over there exactly save that tax
money
because la out here yo fam if you want
to save your money
yo don't move here oh [ __ ] no they
[ __ ] taking all your money in
california
sure five dollar gas prices i was [ __ ]
up tweaking
it it's crazy um he said tweaking
speaking
uh so do you have are you are you i mean
we're almost into 2021 are you gonna put
out a new album before the end of the
year i'm assuming not
um another project yeah not another
album another mixtape though
just gonna be a mixtape something to
throw out there yeah technically
are we going to say you still
technically haven't dropped an album
right
all mixed tapes we're considering your
catalog all tapes uh oh yeah my first
album will probably be next
next year who do you want to work with
everyone wants to work with you
now who billy godless billy eilish
that'll be crazy i love billy i remember
the first time we talked we talked how
you like you enjoy country music and she
got a real eclectic taste in music
yeah billy eilish would be wild yeah
also very unexpected
i'd love to hear you want some [ __ ] with
caneloni kelani i think that'd be hard
yeah you know she
uh it's kind of she actually followed me
um not too long ago
and like i told her i love her you love
her yeah i love her
that's what's up she got a boyfriend
it's not yg anymore so you probably
don't have nothing to worry about oh her
and why'd you use the date
oh yeah they were together for like it
was it was i don't know it was kind of
public
they did the song together i love kaname
um who
say they used to date yeah yeah man i
love her though
shout out to kailani would you uh
give me your top five spank bank top
five girls in your spank make now let me
explain you what this means
this is the top five women
you're like if you could bang any chick
in the world for example like for me my
whole life
j lo has been like the pinnacle of
of hot celebrity chicks i want to sleep
with yeah so she's like my wife's in my
top five
one through five obviously but jayla
would be sixth
yeah you had to say that of course shout
out to my wife i
uh won't show you pictures of my wife by
the way
this [ __ ] guy
[ __ ] legend christina milian okay
you got a chance there she's been with a
lot of artists
i want to say she was with the dream
nick cannon and lil wayne
all three yeah you got a chance for
christina milian
that's very realistic
right now oh my god are you crazy he's
sliding in christina millions dms as we
speak
i respect the [ __ ] oh my god he's
really done
it's it's it's official
all right so we got christina million
nia long who else knee along christina
milliant
she's so far um neil on
christina milian um
would rihanna crack your top five i love
her
i feel like her [ __ ] is so good
something about her her [ __ ] just good
i feel like there's reason to believe
that that might be true rihanna
briana yeah christina milia nia long
rihanna
iggy iggy azalea yes well she just broke
up with the
the playboy cardi guy so you got a
chance there is she
she lives out here no what like what
race is she australian
so is that white yeah she's just a but
she's just a [ __ ] generic one
it's crazy bro i've never had no white
[ __ ] you know what's crazy is i
have had white vagina but i'm a white
man and i've
99 black girls i like anything but white
women
is your wife oh no your words my wife's
mexican eggs
yeah i don't [ __ ] with white girls not
my cup of tea sir
yo that [ __ ] it's so crazy i've never
been with a white girl but like
oh coming soon bro you're about to
[ __ ] you're about to be like you're
about to have a show and
once you go overseas is over but you're
about to like be in some random ass like
boise idaho
and it's only white women so boom
so hold on all right so i'll say nia
long rihanna
iggy christina miller one more christina
hmm this last one gotta be it though
like
name some girls um
not because i just can't think of so
many girls i [ __ ] i mean you want me to
go old school
new school school i mean
there's some beautiful women in the
world right now
i won't lie like some you know sweetie
is beautiful but she's obviously in a
relationship with the homie
i was about to say um not not her though
i was about to say like it's it's a lot
of
uh like females who are [ __ ] but it's
these rap [ __ ] or girlfriends yeah you
don't wanna you don't wanna yeah you
don't wanna be disrespectful i mean i'm
gonna keep it respectful right
i won't talk about her though now if if
they were in jail you wouldn't keep it
respectful because that's your ammo
you know oh i have no choice somebody
gotta do it
this is true somebody's got to do it and
it's going to be this guy that's going
to be
me um one more eye boom let me think
man let me think uh uh
hmm i feel like you about to stir some
[ __ ] up let's stir it up man
i don't even want to say that only one
i don't even want to say that okay
preface it by saying if she was single
this would be a single oh she is then
[ __ ] let it fly
let it fly who gives a [ __ ] ah
let it fly bruh she's single who cares
the only person you can mention he's
gonna get me
the only person you could mention that
would stir up some [ __ ] where you like
ruin your career is like maybe beyonce
but it wouldn't ruin your career but
yo i love beyonce no no no but [ __ ] be
consistent no no
no i didn't mean to say that
hey look i so it's a one you got you got
limits
i can't say that guys crazy he he has
limits but to the limits is like people
like beyonce
i can't fight yo beyonce nicki minaj
you can't do that no no no the barbs are
crazy facts
okay so but know what i was gonna say i
love beyonce of course
but like you a [ __ ] respect jay-z so
much first yeah i wouldn't even have
bring them
give me the name that you were gonna say
so we're gonna take them out of
conversation what's the name you're
gonna say aj if you ever wanna come talk
to me bro like my [ __ ] bro
i [ __ ] with you yeah yeah people don't
realize you're from syracuse originally
i'm from
new york [ __ ] but give me the name you
were gonna say oh just stir it up [ __ ]
it
we listen bro we call this one
ruby rose yes she hasn't only fans
yeah did you did you subscribe but
that's my friend though so she's your
friend but you'd [ __ ] her
yeah no no no no no no we don't had a
crazy interview
now i gotta i gotta you know i i don't
i don't [ __ ] with nobody right right
like i don't but i don't lie like by the
time this interview come out
i might have a girlfriend you might so
let's just be clear
so that's what i'm saying right this is
november 4th this is november 4th
so you might have a girlfriend so so
just we got to preface that so look
cause
it's this one girl that you like that's
that's yeah she's like your main main
for show like you see the potential
like yeah out of the gate she got it all
she got everything
so ruby rose is number five thanks but
when me when i get with shorty this is
it yeah i ain't even
is she popular yeah if no no that's the
way she'd be chilling but i
i i won't lie like she got like 100 000
followers now
like but like
she had like 2 000 at first
oh [ __ ] yeah so [ __ ] got crazy like and
they started following her [ __ ] but
samaria samaria uh davis oh he just put
it out there
well with that sir we're gonna end the
interview facts hey man
uh i don't mind cause everybody know
when it's like
i know these rap [ __ ] gonna try to
[ __ ] work but she like one of them like
[ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ] about none of these
[ __ ] well listen man
and if y'all slaughter her i'm gonna let
y'all know right now like come see me
man i'm i'm ready to die about that
[ __ ] well god damn
ready to die shout out to biggie smalls
and we we're gonna end the interview uh
tulsi appreciate you yo go get the
project new project coming before the
top of the year
and uh man run up all your [ __ ]
let's go sam don't be mad at me when you
see this boom i love you